Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Quand j’étais petite,
j’ai eu un rêve,
celui d’être danseuse.
Pourtant, nous ne naissons pas tous égaux,
nous n'avons pas tous les mêmes chances.
Les enfants ne savent pas ces choses-là.
J’étais une petite fille noire,
ma mère était femme de ménage
et mon père était maçon.
Pour danser,
j’ai dû me battre contre les préjugés
et contre les normes.
Ma mère m’a permis de partir
au Bolshoi Ballet Academy, en Russie.
Les portes ne m’étaient pas
grandes ouvertes.
Alors, comment suis-je devenue danseuse ?
En fait, dans ma vie,
j’ai souvent forcé les portes
et parfois, j’ai dû en construire.
Finalement, mon père et moi,
on fait le même métier.
Lui construit des maisons
et moi, je construis des portes.
Plus sérieusement, je me suis
toujours interrogée sur les normes
et notre rapport à celles-ci.
Dans les ballets classiques,
comme dans la culture populaire,
le blanc évoque le bien,
la pureté, l’innocence.
Le noir évoque le mal,
le désespoir, la mort.
Ce qui me fascine, c’est de comprendre
comment on a transposé
cette idée à l’être humain.
Le cygne blanc et le cygne noir
sont la même personne.
C’est un des rôles les plus prestigieux
du ballet classique
et on a souvent des danseuses
étoiles blanches dans ce rôle.
On ne demande pas à la danseuse qui
l’incarne de se maquiller la peau en noir,
son costume suffit à représenter
son alter ego noir.
En revanche, il est d’usage
dans de nombreuses compagnies
de maquiller en noir
les rôles secondaires,
comme dans la « Danse des négrillons »,
renommée la « Danse des enfants »,
dans « La Bayadère »,
ou comme le rôle du Maure
dans « Petrouchka ».
Alors, la question est la suivante :
comment les normes
véhiculent-elles parfois nos préjugés ?
Est-ce normal d’être un individu
blanc, hétérosexuel, riche
ou est-ce un privilège ?
Cela dépend essentiellement des barrières
que la société imposera
à celles et ceux
qui ne répondent pas à ces critères.
Il y a plus de pauvres sur Terre.
On pourrait donc penser que
la norme serait d’être pauvre.
Pourtant, la société privilégie les riches
en leur donnant accès
à une meilleure éducation,
en leur permettant de vivre dans
des villes où les loyers sont élevés
et où se concentrent
les opportunités professionnelles.
Une formation de danse classique
en France avoisine les 60 000 euros,
en incluant l’éducation, l’internat,
les familles d’accueil le week-end,
le coût des pointes
et des justaucorps de danse
ainsi que les cours particuliers.
Soixante mille euros,
c’est une somme astronomique quand on sait
que le SMIC est d’environ 1 200 euros.
Et la France est plutôt un bon élève,
puisqu’à Londres et à New York, il faudra
compter plus de 150 000 à 200 000 euros
si vous ne bénéficiez pas d’une bourse.
Lorsqu’on est privilégié,
on n’affronte pas ces problématiques
et de ce fait, on ne les voit pas.
Donc notre société a tendance
à accentuer l’écart
qui existe entre les privilégiés
et ceux qui ne le sont pas.
Prenons l’exemple un peu
caricatural de cette porte :
la hauteur d’une poignée de porte.
Personne dans cette salle
ne se questionne sur cette norme,
étant donné que tout le monde ici
mesure entre 1,50 m et deux mètres.
Pourtant, les personnes de petite taille
mesurent en moyenne 1,20 m.
D’autres, à mobilité réduite, ne peuvent
pas développer la même force
pour actionner une poignée.
Des lois inclusives
ont réglé cette question
afin de permettre à ces personnes
de se déplacer sans l’aide d’un tiers.
Cela paraît évident,
mais voyez plutôt cet exemple.
Les normes ne doivent pas s’adapter
à chacun d’entre nous,
mais elles doivent inclure tout le monde.
Les normes ne sont pas figées,
elles doivent évoluer avec notre société.
Il en est de même
dans le milieu du ballet.
Malgré son aspect
traditionaliste élitiste,
il doit évoluer avec son époque.
Ses pratiques rétrogrades seront amenées
à disparaître partout dans le monde.
Alors, comment faire évoluer les normes ?
Et pourquoi sont-elles
si difficiles à affronter ?
Il y a ici deux éléments importants.
Premièrement, ceux que la norme privilégie
peuvent penser qu’ils perdraient quelque
chose si cette norme disparaissait.
Cela peut être vrai.
Mais pensez à cette question :
que perd celui qui est
privilégié par la norme ?
Et que gagne celui qui a été
défavorisé par la norme ?
Il existe de nombreux exemples de normes
qui ont disparu
et qui nous scandaliseraient
tous aujourd’hui.
Du moins, je l'espère.
D’autres exemples de normes
qui font l’actualité
parce qu’elles scandalisent une proportion
toujours plus large de la société.
Deuxièmement, le cadre légal doit
évoluer pour fixer ces normes
afin d’empêcher ceux qui en bénéficient
d’agir en toute impunité.
Mais il appartient à chacun d’entre nous
d’entendre raison
et de ne pas s’enfermer dans des idées
préconçues, dans les normes du passé.
Moi, je suis danseuse.
et ce mot signifie que je ne devrais pas
m’exprimer au-delà de mes pointes.
La première porte que je veux construire :
démocratisons les arts classiques.
Le futur Banksy, la future Sylvie Guillem
ou le prochain Mozart
habitent peut-être à Trappes
dans un vingt mètres carrés.
Dans les milieux artistiques,
et dans le ballet en particulier,
il y a une compétition intense.
C’est dur, je ne vous le cache pas.
Quand j’allais à la danse,
je savais que je devais être
meilleure que mes camarades.
Pour réussir, il fallait que
je me distingue par mon talent.
Il y a de nombreux rapports de force
entre les danseurs,
entre les maîtres de ballet qui nous
coachent et la direction artistique.
Ils existent partout dans la société.
Je dirais que le ballet rend
ces rapports de force plus violents
pour plusieurs raisons.
C'est un milieu traditionaliste, élitiste.
Les places se vendent
entre 50 et 250 euros,
dans la plupart des grandes compagnies.
Nous, danseurs, n’avons pourtant
que des contrats à durée déterminée,
plutôt précaires, alors que nos supérieurs
ont souvent des contrats bien protégés.
Cette asymétrie alimente
une omerta dans ce milieu.
Il n’était pas rare de voir
de nombreux abus passer sous silence.
On se tait
pour ne pas perdre notre contrat.
On se tait pour ne pas laisser
paraître nos faiblesses.
Il n'y a souvent pas de ressources
humaines dans les compagnies,
pas de syndicat.
On est livré à nous-mêmes dans ce métier.
Alors que faire quand une amie me dit
qu’un de ses supérieurs l’a embrassée
de force, a abusé d’elle ?
Ou quand une autre sombre dans l’anorexie
parce qu’on lui a demandé
de perdre du poids ?
Ces phrases ont été dites
pendant des répétitions.
« Rentre tes fesses de négresse. »
« Tu danses comme une femmelette. »
Pour ma part, j’ai vécu
récemment le racisme
et j’ai décidé
de ne pas rester silencieuse.
« On ne devrait pas la prendre
parce qu’elle est noire. »
Voilà ce que ma supérieure a dit
de moi après une audition.
Ce sont ces comportements intolérables
que je ne supporte plus
et que je souhaite combattre aujourd’hui.
Alors si, comme moi, vous avez été victime
d’une situation d’abus,
si vous avez subi des violences
psychologiques ou physiques,
je vous en supplie, parlez-en.
Trouvez une personne de confiance
et parlez-lui.
Mais ne restez pas dans le silence.
J’ai osé parler en prenant le risque
de ne plus jamais redanser
parce que la plupart des directeurs
de compagnie se connaissent
et que les nouvelles vont vite
dans le milieu du ballet.
Mais après avoir parlé de mon histoire,
les témoignages que j’ai reçus
m’ont donné la certitude
qu’il y a quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne pas dans ce milieu.
Et je ne crois pas
que le ballet soit un cas isolé.
Notre société, même si beaucoup
de progrès ont été faits,
a une tendance mécanique
à promouvoir les comportements agressifs.
On prend par la force, on exploite
jusqu’à ce qu’il n’y ait plus rien.
On produit en détruisant,
en polluant, en tuant.
On a notre part de responsabilité
dans tout cela.
Mais aujourd’hui, on en a conscience
et on peut adresser ces questions
à l’humanité tout entière.
Je me suis demandé
quelle était ma responsabilité,
pourquoi je devrais parler
des discriminations que j’ai subies.
Et ma réponse était une évidence.
C’est la deuxième porte
que j’ai construite
pour me libérer de cette omerta.
Je le dois parce que je le peux.
Parce que si je ne fais rien,
rien ne changera.
Ma responsabilité comme la vôtre
ne se limite pas aux normes.
Elle ne se limite pas
au confort individuel.
Il y a vous, et il y a nous.
Parlez pour ceux qui ne le peuvent pas,
osez pour ceux qui n’osent pas.
Chacun a la possibilité d’améliorer
les conditions de vie de quelqu’un d’autre
et chaque pas en avant vers un monde
plus juste, plus équitable, compte.
Je me suis attaquée à la plus prestigieuse
compagnie de danse d’Allemagne.
Non pas pour moi, mais pour toutes ces
petites filles et tous ces petits garçons
qui partagent le même rêve que le mien.
Après avoir cherché à résoudre
le problème en interne,
j’ai pris conscience que les institutions
ont tendance à les enterrer
au lieu de les résoudre,
préférant garder la face
que d’agir et de changer.
Pourtant, toutes ces institutions sont
faites de gens comme vous et moi.
Alors si nous pouvons changer,
si nous pouvons nous améliorer,
elles le peuvent aussi.
C'est une question d'éducation.
C’est une question de volonté.
J’ai subi le racisme, je me suis exprimée,
j’ai brisé le silence et porté plainte
pour que finalement
mon expérience soit entendue
et qu’une réconciliation ait été possible.
Pardonner, c’est se donner
une chance d’avancer.
C’est la troisième porte
que je vous souhaite de franchir.